What does it feel like when a man penetrates you?
Can you explain it in a way where men can understand, Oh wait,
did your first time hurt?
I do remember it being a pleasant experience,
but it was painful and I was sore for like days after.
No, it didn't hurt at all. Actually it was really careful about it.
And he made sure to ask me if it did hurt or not. Yeah.
I wasn't used to have any, having anything in my vagina.
Like I didn't even use tampons at the time.
I don't know bleeding, anything like that. It was like very great. We did it.
It was done. We got burritos after it was very enjoyable.
I wish there was some sort of education on like more of the
emotional side, because after like my first,
it took me so long to even like kiss anyone again,
just because it felt very odd to me because this was like something that had
been reserved for one person for a very long time. And like,
I was trying to navigate like dating and relationships.
And I felt like I couldn't have a normal relationship because any man coming on
to me, even if that's what the setting was,
even if it's something that I would've wanted to do, it just felt wrong to me.
What does it feel like when a man penetrates you?
Can you explain it in a way where men can understand? Oh wait.
Oh, that's so weird.
And I try my best for a man.
When you really have the urge to go to the bathroom,
that feeling that like relief, except for it's the reverse.
You don't like, feel it in one spot. It kind of like,
you feel it, you know, when you have to, like, you put like a,
like a lid on something it's like oddly satisfying.
When you put a lid on a jar of pickles and S did I really just describe it as
that? Do you ever worry your vagina doesn't look normal?
Yes.
I felt like I didn't have any formal.
Not anymore. I definitely did at one point,
because then I would hear like this whole rhetoric about like roast beef or
whatever. And I was like, my vagina kind of does look like roast beef.
And I don't know why that's a problem. If you're on birth control,
how does it affect your body? So it's not something I'm currently on,
but when I was on it, it, I believed that it was clear my acne,
because that's something I heard for a long time,
but it did the complete opposite. It made it worse. I for sure had mood swings.
And I feel like that's not who I am at all.
It might take you several different tries with birth control to find one that
works for your body. For me, I loved the NuvaRing. My sister tried the NuvaRing.
She gained like 15 pounds and hated it.
The main thing is to make sure you're always taking it because I have a tendency
to forget. And that's when it really messes you up with the implant. Um,
I bled for almost a year straight, so that wasn't fun at all.
If you have any questions, just talk to a doctor about sex on your period.
How in all caps? Um,
never have I ever, well,
I did have my period for a year straight,
so that's something I had to figure out.
You gotta use a towel and a condom. Honestly,
it feels better because your hormones are so all over the place that it's kinda
it's, it's not as, it's not as bad as everyone thinks it is.
Personally to me,
sex on my period just seems uncomfortable because I'm already cramping up a lot.
You're already really sensitive by your vagina.
Things like diva cups and different types of period products,
per se, that can go inside of you and you can have mess free.
That's how they advertise it. Mass free period sex.
Is it normally? I know some people who would say no, it's not.
And I disagree wholeheartedly. I feel like people were like,
I don't mess around. I don't want you. I don't do anything that builds up.
And I feel like masturbation is a way to kind of let it out.
I do it probably every day. Have you ever questioned your sexuality?
Yes. I went through like a whole questioning phase.
Like would I ever really be attracted to another woman?
I think that's very normal for people to go through.
Even just like coming to terms with the fact that you're straight.
I had one very strong crush on a girl,
but I think it was more of an infatuation with just the way she looked.
I wanted to look like her more so than being with her.
Have you ever had an orgasm? I have not. Yes.
Yes. Nope.
Growing up, especially during puberty,
there was sort of like this feeling ashamed tag around girls, um,
going through puberty and feeling horny. Like if I felt a little horny,
I was like, Oh no, like this isn't normal. If I'm horny,
I just sit through it and I don't do anything about it.
And I wait until it passes. But because of that, like later my body,
like just when it's like about to organism my body like shuts down. It's like,
no, you're not going to that's. And that's just my mind blocking it,
which is something I'm working on.
Have you ever faked an orgasm? Hmm,
one time in my early days. Cause I felt so bad,
but never again. I felt like a shame that I was taking too long.
You kind of have this expectation that you're going to act like the girls in the
pornos.
Is it important to find a partner that can make you orgasm if they can't make
you orgasm? At first,
I think you should find a partner who's willing to learn and adjust to what you
want. So you both can have a better time.
And I think if they learn to adjust to what you like,
then their partner worth having around them nets.
That's the partner you want to have sex with.
For so long, I was with partners.
I mean for five or six years when I was first having sex,
I was with partners again and again, that never made me orgasm,
but I also didn't know how to make myself work as them.
So I wasn't masturbating. I wasn't communicating with my partners.
I didn't know what positions were turn-ons for me.
I had to have a conversation with him cause I'm like, I'm lying.
I'm lying to me. I'm lying to him.
The whole experience just could be so much better.
And so I remember he was laying in bed and we had the conversation and
he was saying, he's like, Oh my gosh, I'm so sorry.
So it's not necessarily important for me to be with a partner that makes me
orgasm.
But it is important for me to be with a partner that prioritizes my pleasure.
Do you feel like you mostly just accommodate men and what they want during sex?
I definitely get like nervous in the sense of like, am I performing well,
am I doing a good job at first? Yes.
As I started to be with more people,
I started to realize they start to ask, well, what do you want me to do?
What do you like? And I was like, what, what do I like?
That's I don't know. What do you consider assault or rape?
I think I may have been, but I don't exactly.
I know.
I know a lot of people are taught rape or assault. Is this big, scary,
aggressive thing.
It could be something like with someone you're really comfortable with or
someone you considered yourself to trust.
Is it okay if I talk about an assault?
Cause like my first time was like a coercion kind of situation.
I knew at some point I wanted to do it with that person,
but I just didn't feel like I was ready per se.
And I was pressured into it, which was something that like,
we're not really taught,
taught about like coercion and stuff like that in school and really the depth of
consent. So I didn't really have the understanding. Like I just,
because I did say yes eventually and it did end up going that way that
that's not okay. So many of us have this question.
I've had very personal conversations with dear friends who didn't come to
terms with the fact that they had been assaulted or raped until five or six
years later, if you can afford, or if your insurance covers it,
get some professional advice and guidance on this,
because this is a question that really needs to
be talked about more.
And then last question. What is something that you wish you were in fact that,
that girl's map.
[Inaudible] the range of consent and what is no,
I wish I was taught more about sex, not being such a shameful thing.
For women.